after three years 12 weeks and five days
the moment of true Redemption finally
nears closer outside the main Cruise
base Yuji sits with a mai going over
their past experiences together knowing
that am I had managed to save Angel
after sakuna sent to hurling through
some of the nearby buildings he thanks
him as now they still have some kind of
chance on this messed up situation this
confuses our Jewish Japanese man because
from what he's heard Yuji had no way of
fighting without sakuna's strength buff
however our boy explains that just
recently he was informed that his body
is like a curse object dipped in
sakuna's energy now he's gonna eat
anything to Pummel that creep and save
his boy having strolled inside chosu
hands Yuji this extremely important
piece of information it's a book that
records all of Yuki's Soul research
along with some more information on the
prison realm itself Yuji thinks choso
but not for the book instead he says
he's thankful for his brothers well
that's how I've interpreted her as choso
tells him that it's okay they'll live on
inside of him which is freaking massive
if you think about it like I think this
just proves that Yuji has already
consumed all of the other cursed worms
and they're all currently chilling out
inside of us in a world my actual theory
on all of us here is that the image
chose her head in his head yes the
picnic one that made him like
collaterally floor and Yuji vs chose's
fight well like with what we've seen
recently with sakona and him being
foreshadowed on the cover of chapter one
or something like that there are so many
things that are brought up earlier for
specific reasons and this is another
that picnic will happen yogis in a world
will change from the hellish landscape
it was before to what we saw in choso's
Vision skipping away from the boys
though chilling up against the wall
smoking a Black shoko just thinks on how
Gojo promised he wouldn't leave anyone
alone but now they're idiots all alone
and there are a bunch of monsters
needing his help she pleads for Gojo to
come back as everyone needs him everyone
does indeed need our man and like half
of the globe expected with Hannah having
been healed just previously takaba
offers to decorate the building with
some origami to celebrate his return so
as we're all presumed when Gojo first
got trapped like I think kingjaku told
him specifically when he was explaining
what the curse realm was but time
doesn't physically run in that prison
realm so due to this they don't know
what Gojo felt and they last 19 days
since he was sealed he doesn't know what
happened with his Inn and Marquee with
mikami and numarky the remnants of
Shibuya and everything that has happened
after that point for almost half of this
series he's been sealed now which is
only 19 days in the JFK world but still
it might have felt like just a moment
for Gojo or as if every second was like
a hundred years inside of the prison
realm so matachi level of like ginjutsu
or something so because of that fact
Angel is worried about Gojo's mental
state Shoku points out also that if he
is confused and upset then it could be
really dangerous to unseal Gojo where
they are now instead of the building
then everyone decided to take the back
door and make their way to an
undisclosed area to attempt Gojo's
unsealing having placed the realm on
their ground in front of them and umaki
gives the signal and henna who was
floating above activates Angel's curse
technique Jacob's letter just like with
mikami a mess of Blast Of Life beans
down upon the prison realm weirdly
though as Yuji quietly approaches
calling out for a Sensei he realizes
that there is nothing at all he looks
over at the other vessel and henna tries
to explain that it isn't her fault like
they had expected earlier Gojo might
have just turned evil and the light from
Jacobs later could have actually made
him disappear however their thoughts are
shattered as they suddenly feel the
Earth itself begin to roll elsewhere
Kenny the big brain antagonist like a
man went full anime here and was like
huh I planned for this moment and placed
him 8 000 meters deep in a trench he'll
never Escape he'll drown before he even
makes it to the surface it's most likely
the Mariana Trench what he's you know
stuck him in here but I'm not 100 sure
it's near Japan and the Mariana Trench
it's also near Japan but after 19
grueling days or three years 12 weeks
and five days in our own world saturu
Gojo returned appearing in a blaze of
pure deadness Gojo floats there ready to
face and destroy the who stole his
best friend's body kinjaku tries to
irritate the greatest sorcerer to ever
love but Gojo tells the fame that he
should be chosen his words carefully as
these are his final moments taken by
surprise himself though goju easily
manages to block a few strikes from the
other body swapper taking his new
appearance in goja states that Mega me
has indeed changed from the last time
they saw each other finally remember
when sakuna said the day he takes over
Yuji he'll wipe out Gojo first well now
with him having swapped up his skin
sakuna just mentions that it turned out
to be the sprite's body but either way
nothing has changed hearing this though
goju ridicules the king of curses as
some weak loser who decided to run away
from Yuji and now after switching up
he's acting all high and mighty UT
utterly pathetic a roommate who's just
showed up as enraged with the fact that
Gojo mocked her man and tries to attack
but gets utterly photorized in one panel
as Gojo seems with flying through a
building with a single punch and like
like this is actually insane sheer loan
was able to fight or hold off Maki and
Yuji alone along with that time in
Shibuya where she stopped everyone
allowing her and kinjaku to safely
Escape that battle but nah Gojo in to it
in one punch dude is completely and
utterly Different Kenny then suddenly
drops back in and stops Akuna from
continuing with the abuse hurling Gojo
also jokingly thinks he's got some stuff
to get done before they battle it out he
mocks the king of curses asking if he
was really listening to a guy that
looked like a poorly sore and rubbish
bag continuing with Kenny's chat though
kaju asks for the current date and after
hearing that it's nearing the end of
November proposes that this entire
battle take place on the 24th of
December having heard Gojo's proposal
kinjaku cracks up at the Romanticism of
that specific situation and agrees so do
we all remember back to the very
beginning of the series when Yuji had
asked Gojo if sukuna is stronger than
him of course at the time Gojo stated
that it may be tough if sukuna regains
all of his powers causing Yuji to ask if
he'd lose Gojo probably been a little
cocky to the newcomer at the time had
replied that he'd win though now here
back facing off against the strongest
foes in this story goju States the same
thing I will win
[Music]
boom so that there is the day no one
other than dead kojo was freed from the
prison realm it was just you know like
something a little bit different on my
channel but I really wanted to cover
This Magnificent moment on my channel
like everyone house is probably going to
because it's absolutely amazing and
we've been waiting for it for years now
like if you've been reading the manga so
I I'm I'm too stoked to actually have it
finally come true like the hype I had
while writing and recording this was
absolutely insane right now I'm actually
curious as to if Yuji and everyone else
even realizes he's already made it
inside of Tokyo or wherever plus am I
tripping bit of this man just invaded
barrier after April was made that no one
else could join Maybe I'm Wrong in
kenjaku and sakuna have already left
that area but I'd love to know your
thoughts on that down below I think what
we're going to get next over this like
coming month is a bit of training with
Yuji and everyone else building up to
like December the 24th it's so good to
see Gojo back but I'm also curious as to
what geargate has in store for him now
here we see that he hated writing Gojo
because he was so strong now though is
there a way for him to ride it so it
doesn't seem like Gojo just noticed
absolutely everyone and will they be
able to rescue Mega me plus I also love
how like this was foreshadowed just a
few months back with some of the new art
that was posted in combination with this
season 2 announcement this was just
written off the basic translations so a
few things might have changed by the
time that the verse translations come
out on Monday but they're always a bit
of r s as we all know but last time I
accidentally called yodazoo a dude will
like the past the order suit a dude
turns out she was also a female a
thousand years ago as well so that was
my fault there if you want me to cover
everything with sakona versus yodazoo
then post this video to 5K likes and
leave a comment down below with like
what's your favorite Point throughout
this entire story so far I would
absolutely love to know and then I might
cover those specific points as well and
if you are new around here then
subscribe as it really helps out with
the algorithm plus if you want Early
Access and to like a pair with these
awesome new people on the screen then
check out my patreon which I'll leave
down in the description below but for
now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and LC wall in a bit
bye